they have departed Clarence House
the crowds are cheering and a wave there
from the monarch
Crown today
King Charles III alongside his wife
Queen Kimo
[Applause]
[Music]
and now in our view Alistair as
we see that what is a mini procession if
I can call it that making their way the
grandstand getting their first view the
3800 invited guests here as they head
into the palace what happens then
the kid getting in the state Bentley
there will enter through the North
Center gate and then go into the garden
gate to the garden
is where he will go into his Apartments
and there prepare himself in the
clothing he will wear and also the robes
he will be
roped in for the procession the king's
procession
but he's left his home and he's come to
the headquarters of the modern British
Monarchy
foreign